Are you ready to code
mostly fluid layout?
You've already seen this layout before,
but
you haven't had a chance
to modify it's CSS yet.
This quiz you'll be adding some
CSS break points to some HTML, so
that the page layouts
match what you see here.
Here let me show you
what you'll be doing.
In the head of the document
you'll find two style tags.
The first style tag just
has default styles.
And you don't need to change these.
Here let me close them.
The second style tag includes
the responsive styles.
And this is where you're
going to put your breakpoints.
My advice is to write the initial
breakpoints in the source file,
with classes that you might
want to modify at that breakpoint.
Then open the page in the browser, and
toy with the styles using dev tools.
If you got the styles set that you
think look right, go ahead and
change the source files.
Also, try playing around with the order
while you are messing around with
the break points.
It's actually pretty fun.
Check this box once your layout
matches the sites that you see here.
Good luck!